Please welcome Emma Corrin and Josh O'Connor.
(audience cheering)
I love seeing how different you are in real life.
Isn't hair, makeup, wardrobe, just everything?
It's the best, honestly.
It is.
I mean, it's so exciting for us to see you guys like this
you know, and when I'm doing my thing,
it's like, I can see what you really look like.
And then I have to say also,
I'm immediately transported the second I'm in.
And I too, as an actor, it's like it changes
your body language when you put on the clothes.
And everybody's marveling at these side-by-sides
of how impeccably right that you've got it.
And it does make a huge difference
because then everybody can sort of fall
into the history of...
I mean, I really don't know how else to explain it
other than, this was at the center of all of our universes.
And I do want to share something with you.
Okay, we probably have a screenshot of it.
But this is actually here,
I keep this with me at the studio.
There is me presenting the ET doll to Princess Diana
when I was seven years old, in 1982,
at the World Premier of "ET".
Oh. That's...
That's very sweet.
And it was a moment that I will never forget.
And I keep the picture nearby,
because I really was the girl amongst millions
of other girls who grew up with Princess Diana.
And I mean, Emma, what was it like to get into her?
You're so amazing as her.
And I just want to say,
that the first scene you guys have together, to me,
with so poetically choreographed.
And with all the history that we know
about Charles and Diana,
to set the stage in this very coquettish, eyeball,
mysterious, Shakespearian way was really amazing.
Did you like the introduction of these characters?
Yeah, I really did.
I think you've kind of hit the nail on the head there
by saying it sort of Shakespearian.
Because there's such a historical romance
I suppose, associated with that kind of depiction
of two characters meeting
that almost transcends all kind of reality.
And I guess it kind of goes hand-in-hand
with the whole fairy tale thing
that they have going on at the beginning of the series.
I thought it was a really beautiful way
of doing that introduction.
Yeah, I agree.
Yeah, we don't (indistinct) too much, I suppose.
It's like we wanted more going into it,
and then that scene set us up
for just wanting more and more and more.
Josh, I must say, that your acting
with your eyes and your body language,
I also noticed that.
First of all, when actors do internal, I'm sorry,
but it's usually snoozy and boring.
I'm like, I hope you're having fun
because I'm not, watching it because you're internal
and I need something.
You do internal so well.
I was so gripped with your eyes and your shoulders.
You could not say anything in an entire scene
and I was riveted.
And I also loved how I felt like, as a viewer,
I thought I saw your body language
really change when you were with Emma.
Like you were more confident, and more of a cad.
And like your demeanor changed.
Was that conscientious?
'Cause I totally picked that up as a viewer.
Thank you.
Yeah, I suppose, we did lots of work on the kind
of physicality of these characters.
I think you can tell so much with sort of body language,
as you know.
And I think particularly with Charles,
there's kind of very early on
where you sort of picked up on this sort of stoop
he has, and the way he kind of leans his neck out.
And we worked with Polly Bennett,
who's a brilliant movement coach.
And we, we kind of, both Emma and I were keen
to find sort of why they stand like that.
Or where that body language is rooted from.
And so, as we went through the series, we had this sort
of like ongoing joke about just how far Charles does stoop.
And that, as the pressure of the world gets more,
he just sort of winds up like a hunchback really.
I mean, it's quite, it was quite intense.
You, in your own life, I heard a story
about a little date where you showed up,
that wasn't so smooth.
Yeah. I mean, this is quite a long time ago, Drew.
So let's just start with that.
Oh, way in the rear-view mirror.
Yeah. Just like I said, this isn't a recent occurrence.
But yeah, I was maybe like 13, 14
and I did take a girl, it was on a double date.
And my mum had given me not very much money.
So I only had enough money to take us to the cinema.
And we went to the cinema and then it was Easter.
And afterwards, the other guy was like
let's go and get these girls some eggs, like chocolate eggs.
And we went to the chocolate shop
and he got this beautiful egg with the girl's name,
sort of printed with beautiful chocolate writing.
And I got a small egg and then realized, I had no money.
And so she had to buy her own,
which was less than brilliant.
You could just tell her, "Listen I'm going
to be playing Prince Charles in my future.
So, don't worry about"
I should have done.
"The size of the egg."
Emma, I loved a detail, before we go,
that you said, when...
I don't know who you were saying this with,
but that when you felt the nerves of all the attention
being Diana, and all of that energy,
that you should channel it into the performance.
Who do have that conversation with?
So that's a conversation I had with Ben Caron,
one of the directors, just after I got the part actually.
And Ben's sitting me down and saying,
you know, life's going to change a lot.
And, any time you feel overwhelmed or nervous,
or there are people taking photographs of you,
or you end up in the news, use it.
Because it's a completely parallel experience
that you're having.
And it really did come in handy.
Yeah, I remember one day we were filming in London
on the street, and the scene was me being chased
by paparazzi as young Diana.
And then, behind the supporting actors,
who were playing the paparazzi were actual paparazzi
who were there for me.
And it was such a weird, like yeah, colliding of worlds.
But actually weirdly useful.
Wow. I think that's a very smart direction
and you took it so well.
And you're honoring these people who we've grown up with
that are such icons in this world
and doing them such justice.
And we love it.
And I think you guys are incredible.
And I was so thrilled that you would come on the show today.
Thank you, Emma and Josh.
Season four of "The Crown" is out now.
Everybody knows it. Everybody's watching it.
It's the talk of everything.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)